[Musica]
Buongiorno Oggi voglio raccontarvi una
storia che ci riguarda tutti e per farlo
vorrei cominciare
da uno dei miei figli vorrei mostrarvi
un video
questo è Sofia e qui in questo video a
due giorni di vita e come tutti i bimbi
che hanno due giorni di vita tutti i
neonati che hanno due giorni di vita si
muove continuamente Ma non si muove
perché ci sia qualcuno che la stimola
dall'esterno oppure perché ha una forte
voglia e intenzione di farlo si muove
perché il suo sistema nervoso
continuamente Lancia messaggi ai muscoli
dicendoci dicendogli di muoversi e per
questo motivo li chiamiamo movimenti
spontanei
tutti quanti ci siamo mossi così quando
eravamo molto piccoli abbiamo iniziato
nell'utero intorno ai due mesi di vita
dal concepimento e ci siamo mossi così
per tutti gli altri sette mesi della
gestazione e poi anche per altri 5 mesi
dopo la nascita
7 + 5 fa 12 Quindi noi per un anno
intero ci siamo mossi spontaneamente
tutti quanti avevamo questi movimenti
spontanei E quest'anno è stato un anno
molto importante perché noi siamo
passati da avere 20 milioni di neuroni
fino ad averne 150 miliardi
in pratica se ci pensate fate il conto è
come se ogni secondo di questo anno così
importante siano nati nei nostri
cervello nel nostro sistema nervoso
5.000 neuroni 5000 neuroni Al secondo
una cosa enorme
ecco Ma perché noi ci siamo mossi così
per 12 mesi e cosa ha a che fare questo
con questo numero Altissimo di neuroni
che si sono moltiplicati Ecco noi ci
siamo mossi per 12 mesi
per un motivo molto preciso che i
ricercatori hanno studiato sia nel
modello animale sia nell'uomo in
particolare quello che hanno visto E che
in questa fase Così precoce
per ogni segnale che dal cervello
partiva e andava tutto il corpo un
segnale opposto e contrario dal corpo
tornava al cervello e trasportava tutte
le informazioni sensoriali per esempio
quelle tattili se torniamo a pensare al
feto
l'effetto che si muove trasportava tutte
le informazioni del braccio del feto che
esercita una pressione sulla parete
dell'utero oppure del liquido amniotico
che scorre sulla pelle del feto tutte
queste informazioni
tornano al sistema nervoso e generano
nuove cellule una parte di quelle 5000
di cui abbiamo parlato prima
quindi possiamo dire che il la motricità
spontanea
[Musica]
e soprattutto gli effetti
sensoriali che genera la motricità
spontanea
generano nuove cellule nel cervello
plasmano il cervello il cervello che
plasma se stesso per questo motivo si
parla di
autopoiesi il sistema nervoso l'asma se
stesso quindi sono mesi molto importanti
questi della gestazione e a cosa serve
tutto questo
serve per prepararci alla vita dopo la
nascita per esempio
essere autonomi nel respirare sistema
nervoso contro la ai celti del respiro
oppure
nell'alimentarci Controlla i centri
dell'Assunzione della deglutizione
Oppure ancora distribuire l'ossigeno in
tutto il corpo controllando il sistema
cardiovascolare ecco Ma c'è un'altra
funzione che forse non è meno importante
di queste
e che forse il motivo per cui vi sto
raccontando questa storia qui oggi Ecco
si tratta
della capacità di specchiarci nell'altro
una capacità molto importante perché ci
consente di connetterci con chi ci
garantirà la sopravvivenza per alcuni
mesi o anni con i nostri genitori o chi
si prende cura di noi quindi è molto
importante avere questa capacità già
sviluppata la nascita in qualche misura
ecco per dimostrare che questa capacità
si sviluppa già durante la gestazione
alcuni ricercatori hanno studiato le
gravidanze gemellari cioè quelle
situazioni in cui per nove mesi siamo
costretti a vivere in uno spazio
abbastanza ristretto con un coinquilino
hanno studiato in particolare i
movimenti che facevano questi feti
gemelli e hanno scoperto che quando un
feto tocca il suo gemello utilizza un
gesto molto delicato
in particolare rallenta moltissimo prima
di raggiungere l'obiettivo
cos'è che invece non fa quando tocca se
stesso o quando tocca la parete
dell'utero e questi ricercatori hanno
interpretato questi dati
immaginando che siano dovuti a una
qualche consapevolezza del feto che c'è
un altro significativo c'è un
interlocutore nel quale in qualche modo
ha già rispecchiarsi
però se ci pensiamo bene Non c'è bisogno
di una gravidanza
gemellare per andare a fare emergere
questa predisposizione perché tutti
quanti abbiamo avuto un interlocutore
già nella pancia questo interlocutore è
stato ovviamente
vostra madre per questo motivo alcuni
altri ricercatori sempre italiani hanno
fatto un altro studio in gravidanze
tipiche a 25 settimane sono andati a
monitorare l'apertura della bocca del
feto l'ecografia
e hanno scoperto che questi movimenti di
apertura
aumentavano significativamente Quando la
mamma pronunciava dei suoni comunicativi
mentre non si modificavano affatto
Quando la mamma produceva altri tipi di
suoni per esempio masticare oppure
quando nella stanza venivano prodotti
altri suoni ancora come se il feto fosse
in grado di risuonare motoriamente con
la voce della mamma e anche loro hanno
interpretato questo come l'emergenza di
questa capacità di relazionarci e già
avviene durante la gravidanza
Ecco possiamo quindi pensare che
la letteratura ci scientifica ci sta
convincendo che questa capacità si forma
già durante la vita intrauterina e Del
resto questo spiegherebbe perché noi
alla nascita siamo in grado di imitare
di fare gli stessi movimenti che fa
l'adulto di fronte a noi per esempio
imitiamo l'apertura della bocca oppure
imitiamo la protrusione della lingua e
questi dati sono estremamente
solidi nella letteratura scientifica una
cosa dimostrata molto bene e tornando a
Sofia questo è ancora lei che piano
piano
limita il suo papà e apre la bocca di
fronte a lei
in questo caso ha quattro giorni
ecco Ma
cosa ci insegna tutto questo che abbiamo
detto finora soprattutto Cosa insegna a
un neuropsichiatra infantile come me che
si occupa di neonati ad alto rischio
neonati nati molto prima del termine dei
neonati con una sofferenza La nascita
neonati con un inizio difficile della
vita secondo me ci insegna che una delle
cose più importanti in un bambino nelle
sue primissime fasi della vita è proprio
questo incontro questa relazione che si
stabilisce
con la mamma soprattutto anche perché la
letteratura ci dice che la qualità di
questa relazione correla Poi con lo
sviluppo sociale con lo sviluppo
dell'empatia ma anche con lo sviluppo
cognitivo a lungo termine e quindi il
nostro dovere in queste gravidanze con
dalla nascita difficile in questa idea
di così vulnerabili e il nostro dovere
proteggerlo questo momento questo
momento iniziale e per questo nel
laboratorio che dirigo qui a Pisa
insieme a tante ricercatrici soprattutto
fantastiche Noi abbiamo negli anni
sviluppato un modello di intervento
precoce in queste coppie in queste diadi
così vulnerabili un intervento basato
appunto sulla promozione di questo
momento di incontro momento di relazione
precoce
e per questo qualunque cosa facciamo nel
nostro intervento per esempio quello che
facciamo verso il bambino
per esempio il contenimento posturale
terapia del dolore l'igiene del sonno la
facciamo pensando che questo lo renderà
più disponibile alla relazione precoce a
quei momenti di arricchimento tutto
quello che facciamo per i genitori per
la mamma l'ascolto il sostegno
psicologico Il trasferimento di
conoscenze il cosiddetto empowerment lo
facciamo pensando che questo possa
promuovere questo momento così
importante e infine quello che facciamo
nell'ambiente
cambiando le luci I contrasti gli spazi
del gioco
tutto questo serve per promuovere il
momento di incontro così cruciale così
importante e questo è quello che abbiamo
fatto per esempio con Marta
una bimba che è nata prima molto molto
prima 24 settimane quasi 4 mesi prima di
quando avrebbe dovuto nascere e pesava
più o meno mezzo chilo e lei ha
veramente avuto un inizio molto
difficile della vita in particolare la
sua difficoltà era visiva lei aveva
importanti difficoltà nella visione e
quindi non riusciva in questo momento di
incontro che noi cercavamo di coltivare
di promuovere a incontrarsi con la mamma
una mamma bravissima e cercava di farsi
toccare di fare sentire il suo odore di
fare sentire la sua voce ma Marta aveva
questa difficoltà visiva importante e
quindi era nella relazione ma non fino
in fondo non riusciva
apprezzarla in pieno e allora abbiamo
modificato l'ambiente abbiamo abbassato
un po' la luce Abbiamo messo
l'attenzione sul volto della mamma
e piano piano Marta ha cominciato a
controllare meglio la sua vista
avvicinarsi di più
a guardare negli occhi la mamma
fino a un certo punto è successo
un piccolo miracolo
Marta ha cominciato a sorridere ha
cominciato a vivere a pieno questa
relazione Ecco
nel nostro laboratorio Noi siamo
convinti e in questo momento che abbiamo
visto in tanti altri che sono seguiti si
siano posati dei mattoncini di quella
che sarebbe diventata Marta oggi che ha
quattro anni
e per questo motivo chiamiamo questo lo
specchiarsi che cura Grazie
[Applauso]